okay I'm gonna show you the best bread
recipe in the world
hiving that gives you the maximum flavor
for the least amount of effort this is a
variation on the no need method and it's
basically about ten minutes work spread
over 20 hours I thought this would be
useful if you're like stuck in the house
for some reason for a while and also
baking your own bread is so useful
because you can turn all of these as raw
ingredients into amazing delicious bread
saves you having to go out to the shops
to buy bread which won't be as good or
as tasty is the thing we're gonna make
so here's what we're gonna use we're
going to use a Dutch oven to do the
baking and stainless steel bowl to do
the mixing the ingredients are three
cups of unbleached all-purpose flour or
if you want you can substitute one of
those cups of flour with a cup of whole
wheat flour 1/4 of a teaspoon of instant
yeast one and a half teaspoons of table
salt a cup of water and the secret to
this recipe is using vinegar and beer to
give it that fermented sourdough kind of
flavor so we'll use 1 tablespoon of
white vinegar and then 1/2 a cup of
cheap lager it doesn't need to be
anything special so I'm using Miller
High Life the champagne of self-delusion
and you don't want to be that's too dark
or too flavorful so cheap like anything
coking is good whatever you've got
around okay let's get started we're
gonna save and mix the dry ingredients
and then pour in the liquids now the
mixing is super easy we don't need to be
very thorough because we'll be leaving
it for 8 to 18 hours to rest which means
the flour has loads of time to absorb
all of the moisture this is good to do
in the evening and leave overnight or in
the before times when we used to go to
work you could mix this in the morning
and then bake it in the evening so just
give it a quick stir like I'm doing here
and bring it together with your hands
you're aiming for a kind of shaggy ball
like consistency like we can see here
then you want to cover it this bowl is a
handy lid we can also use cling film or
saran wrap now it's good to put it
somewhere nice and warm to activate the
yeast like an airing cupboard near a
radiator or like I'm doing here in a
love warms just a slightly above room
temperature okay after the long resting
time we're gonna take the dough out wash
the bowl and give the dough a little bit
of kneading they said that this was
based on the no need method but you
actually want to do a little bit of
kneading we don't really need too much
just enough to even out the dough and
form a bull a bull is just a fancy
baking term for a ball and you make it
by pulling four corners into the middle
of the dough flip it over and do this
kind of twisting motion to pull it into
a ball shape it helps here if the base
is a little bit tacky so the interior of
the dough kind of winds up with some
tension then put it back in the mixing
bowl on top of a sheet of baking
parchment we'll leave this to prove for
another two hours and for the last half
an hour we need to preheat our oven put
the Dutch oven in your normal oven and
whack it up to the highest setting which
for me was 500 Fahrenheit who aren't our
Dutch oven to have enough time to absorb
as much heat as possible just before we
bake the dough we want to sprinkle a
little bit of flour on top and then
score the top with a sharp knife then
take the steaming hot Dutch oven out of
the main open and carefully transfer the
dough into it put the lid back on and
then put them in the oven but reduce the
temperature to 425 Fahrenheit and bake
for exactly thirty minutes when that's
done leave it in the oven but take the
lid off and bake for another five to ten
minutes to get the top of the bread nice
and brown and crispy and then your
lovely loaf of bread is done doesn't
that look good
and there we have it our freshly baked
loaf of bread and they taste absolutely
amazing which I'm sure you agree if you
make it and if you do go and make one
please send me a photo I'd love to see
what they look like you can share them
on Instagram or Twitter and let Dominic
one minute both of those and yeah take
care of yourselves out there and I'll be
back to making my normal science videos
again next week all right bye
[Music]
you